coming soon on the flash
Tuesday more seventies able to control
the weather like that indoors you'd have
to be a weather wizard Oh been waiting
since week one to use that one one more
twenty-fourth snorts back all freeze
over my babies sister first twenty years
ago if one man named himself the
trickster I had 20 years to come up with
the perfect someone was rocking the
unitard there's one villain he wants to
catch the most my mom's killer is still
out there
I will travel back
five minutes hey youtubers is Charlie so
this is gonna be my breakdown to the new
flash trailer they just posted it's
actually got footage for the next three
episodes episodes 15 16 and 17 so I'll
explain who the new characters who meet
and you know what their changing in the
comics most of the people that bring on
the new characters are pretty true to
what they were in the comics though so
let's just go with the big stuff first
Mark Hamill is reprising his trickster
character that he played on the 1990s
series he was actually in two episodes
of the original flash TV series he
played the James Jesse trickster that
was that was the first trickster in the
comics the trickster that we see at the
beginning of this trailer the one that's
grandstanding is the Axl Walker
trickster that's the one that Jeff
John's created during the Wally West's
run he debuted an issue 183 in 2002 in a
story called introducing the trickster
the way they're explaining it on the
show is almost exactly what happened in
the comics so what happens is is that
James jesse trickster goes to prison and
kind of retires and puts the name away
Axl Walker steals all of his props all
of his trickster props in his technology
and uses it to commit crimes calling
himself the trickster James Jesse finds
out about it gets pissed it just
absolutely hates Axl Walker so on the
show he's going to be helping Joe West
and the cops take him down in the comics
it was like a rogue team against rogue
team though it was the same basic story
though the original trickster who at
this point is like an older man just
beats the crap out of Axl Walker and
says never call yourself the trickster
again do not profane the name that's
kind of what the arc is gonna be for
Mark Hamill's trickster I don't know how
they're gonna leave the character or if
he's gonna stay in prison but what I
think we're all hoping to see is if he
gets any scenes with John Wesley Shipp
in the prison in iron Heights prison
that would be so awesome the funny thing
is this trailer begins with the
trickster stuff that's episode 17 so we
won't see that for a while there's no
title for that episode but because a lot
of the trickster stories like the
episodes that Mark Hamill was in all had
tricks during the title
so whatever episode 17 is called it'll
probably have tricks during the title
for that too next we get to see the Mark
Martin weather wizard that's gonna be
the first episode when we come back
that'll be episode 15 his
he's also really true to the comics to
the original Mark Martin origin story
there's a couple small twists just based
on what they did with the Clyde Martin
weather wizard originally in the comics
clyde mardon this character from episode
1 that we saw he was not called the
weather wizard technically he was just a
scientist that developed technology
enabling him to control whether he was
gonna use it to help humanity but his
brother who was kind of a dirtbag mark
Mardon this character here that we're
meeting for the first time he
accidentally kills Clyde with his
weather wand that he created later he
takes the name weather wizard and uses
his brother Clyde's technology to commit
crimes here's what's different about the
show
so first the Mardon brothers as
described by Joe West in the first
episode in the pilot episode are a crime
family so both brothers are bad Clyde
Mardon the weather wizard from the first
episode he was a metahuman who got his
powers in the STAR Labs explosion that's
probably how mark Mardon got his powers
too but unlike Clyde Mardon it seems
like the new weather wizard his brother
mark has much better command of his
abilities look he's had more time to
practice that's what all the crazy waves
and lightning bolts are in the trailer
Cisco has the best joke though when he
calls him weather wizard been waiting
since week one to use that if you
remember they didn't use the name
weather wizard in the pilot episode
so technically mark Mardon will be the
first character they call weather wizard
which is comic book accurate because
Clyde Mardon in the comics was never
called weather wizard moving on to
episode 16 so that's gonna be the second
episode when we come back
that's called rogue time so we're gonna
get to meet golden glider for the first
time Captain Cold sister heat waves in
the episode - but Payton list is the
real attraction here meeting golden
glider for the first time if you
remember she was on tomorrow people with
Robbie Amell although he's not in this
episode just explained golden gliders
powers they're a little bit different
originally in the comics she had like a
a pair of ice skates that would generate
their own ice that she could skate
around in the air on in the new 52
universe she gets metahuman abilities
but they're a little bit different she
has like astral projection on the show
it looks like she has a special gun just
like Captain cold and heat wave so
she'll probably just have special STAR
Labs tech but no idea what the guns
gonna do it'll probably be something
closer to what her abilities are in the
comics there is a rumor that the Rogues
are supposed to appear in the season
finale but I have no IDE
in what capacity or what they're gonna
be doing so this last little bit the
teaser for the reverse-flash is actually
a lead-in to the Flash's first
time-travel incident that's gonna happen
during episode 15 during the weather
wizard episode that's why we see him
running here seeing another version of
himself so when they say the last five
minutes will change the course of
history quote unquote wink wink
they mean it literally and figuratively
Barry Allen will mess with the timeline
a little bit the producer said that his
first time time traveling like
consciously time traveling will be funny
and sad at the same time like a little
bit Groundhog's Day a little bit
terminator remember it's just the first
time that he time travels not the last
time there's also the big WTF with Cisco
looking into the reverse flash - it
looks like part of team flash maybe not
Barry but at least Cisco figures out
that Harrison wells has flash powers but
I don't expect them to completely
explain that it's just the last five
minutes of the episode so it's it's
meant to be like a big WTF that they'll
explain in a later episode it's like
when we first saw Harrison wells with
the yellow suit we didn't see him in the
yellow suit till much much later so
here's my big question for you guys
what's your favorite thing about this
trail like what are you looking forward
to most just based on my Twitter feed it
seems like you guys are most pumped
about seeing Mark Hamill seeing like
Jedi Master trickster on the flash it's
so weird seeing Mark Hamill after he's
been doing all this Star Wars stuff
whenever he started filming the new Star
Wars trilogy again he had to lose a
bunch of weight so he actually he looks
way different than he did just like a
couple years ago hopefully all this
extra attention from Star Wars will get
him some more work so we'll get to see
him do some more fun stuff in the flare
overs I used to call it the arrow verse
but because flash has been kicking so
much but I'm just gonna call it the
flare overs from now on and by the way
we still don't have a name for the
spin-off show yet but they did announced
three new characters that they're
casting one of them is probably rip
hunter I know everyone wants it to be
Booster Gold but I don't think it is the
other two are still kind of in question
they're relatively minor characters I'll
probably do a video for that tomorrow or
Wednesday cuz we have new agents of
shield and I still have a Walking Dead
Q&A to get out so be sure to subscribe
to get all that stuff there's just a
whole lot of really awesome stuff for me
to get to I'm so excited
the really funny thing is is the news
about the arrow casting and like the
Game of Thrones trailer in this flash
trailer all dropped within like 6 hours
of each other
like really
this morning so it's been a really good
Monday so far what you guys wait for the
new stuff you can click here for my
breakdown of the latest Game of Thrones
trailer is completely badass and you can
click here to catch up with my arrow and
flash videos thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys tomorrow now
let's all do the thing
you